who is unknown man he can a modern
forensic investigation finally identify
the mummy known as the screaming man the
first scientific examination took place
in 1886 his coffin was made from
expensive cedar wood but it was blank
totally unadorned in Egyptian theology a
man couldn't enter the afterlife without
his name so there's something disturbing
about the fact that he was left
anonymous next the Victorian examiners
saw that the body had been deliberately
preserved that indicates respect and
status before long they came up with a
dramatic theory to explain it ma sparrow
became convinced that not only was the
screaming man royal but that he had
suffered a violent death
this lecturer and author Susan Redford
travels to medinet habu she's looking
for traces of a disgraced Egyptian
prince who some believe could be unknown
man he this was the palace of Rama
seized the third often referred to as
the last great Pharaoh of Egypt yet a
chance find made in the early 1800s
casts a shadow over his reign this is
the actual court transcripts of trials
of a treasonous conspiracy against the
Pharaoh Rameses the third the papyrus
alleges a palace coup was orchestrated
by a woman called taya she planned to
assassinate Rameses and replace him with
her son Prince Penta where Susan
theorizes that if tail were confident
the people would accept her son as ruler
he must have had some legitimate claim
to the throne there's one scenario that
makes sense to me you have a cheap queen
her name is taya she is replaced by a
younger woman Isis and a bitter rivalry
ensues
Susan believes Penta where could be
unknown man II
Melinda Hartwig is an expert in
interpreting the artwork of ancient
Egyptian tombs the Egyptians didn't
consider a tomb to be the final resting
place but instead the starting point of
a physical journey which began after
death where you can see the extent that
they went to make sure that everything
was here that was needed unknown man he
was mummified which the Egyptians
believed would allow him to live on
after death but he was denied any of the
protective magic which would allow him
to reach the next world but the coffin
of unknown man II was completely bare
not only that the essential protective
items normally placed inside the coffin
were missing and most surprising of all
the sheep or goat skin found around the
mummy of the screaming man may have been
considered ritually impure by the
ancient Egyptians some experts have
concluded that for the screaming man to
be buried in this manner means that
whoever he was must have died in
disgrace the forensic examination of
unknown man II is now under way what dr.
Hawass and his team are hoping for is a
clue some hard evidence which will allow
them finally to give unknown man II a
name what I can say about this mummy
number one is the age and I would assume
between 25 till 40 years of age
this estimate is based on a number of
factors like the condition of key joints
and the appearance of the teeth until
now most people believe that the
screaming man died young it now seems
the screaming man was probably older
than first thought the correct age to
have been the adult son of ramasees the
third evidence from the cat-scan now
suggests the data this could be the
mummy of bento or the son of Ramesses
the third if those who buried him
intended to damn him their attempts have
in a sense been thwarted we can't
restore his name we don't have final
proof that this is Penta ware but we can
restore his face
facial anthropologists have now
recreated his skull individual muscles
have been molded into place his skin has
been restored this is the face that in
death took on a scream the face of the
screaming man